hey Doug Walker here talking about
something I don't normally talk about uh
you know I talk about a lot of Disney
stuff on here I love Disney even though
I know it's a big evil corporation I
love it I love the childhood memories it
brings out I love the innocence of it
and all that
Jamal T stuff so I want to talk about
this short that came out before the
movie Coco it was a frozen short I used
the word short very loosely because it's
like 21 minutes I think and it's kind of
like pissed off a lot of people which is
interesting frozen Ari has gotten kind
of his backlash cuz it's everywhere
people are sick of let it go and the
merchandise is everywhere and stuff
which is very understandable even when
the short started I was saying you know
I like the movie but getting really sick
of frozen and it's got this huge
backlash of people so saying like yeah
we were here to see Coco we didn't want
to see a preview for frozen - you know
that's even what I called it we didn't
want to see another reason to go and buy
Elsa and Anna dolls and you know hang
little Olaf ornaments on the tree and
stuff as soon as I went to the store
afterwards I saw a little Olaf ornaments
I saw Elsa and Anna and the new outfits
and stuff out like this is why that
short was made so it's got this big
backlash partially because it is so long
and kids were getting antsy and they're
like when's Coco gonna stir when this is
gonna begin and I kind of wanted to look
at whether or not it's deserving of the
hate because I'm kind of on the styler
I'm kind of in the middle leaning
towards I don't know if it is here's the
big thing you know
frozen is still friggin huge I mean it's
just like how many years through that
movie come out and it's still a monster
it's still selling tons of merchandise
and they're just they can't get out the
merchandise enough you know it's
probably gonna be like you know the new
Lion King if it's not already I mean
it's just been relevant for so many
years so it's one of those things where
it's like you just know they were
wishing goddammit why didn't we put this
before the good dinosaur
some like that because cocoa is a good
movie it's a really really good movie
it's getting great reviews and people
are flooding to go see it because it's
so wonderful so this did not need a
frozen short this honestly would have
been fine to be put like the short lava
before which is like what seven that is
something like that and Disney and Pixar
are some of the few studios that are
still putting out shorts before their
films which is very rare that they used
to do it a lot they used to show
cartoons before films these to show it's
gonna study is to show commercials but
they are doing that now aren't they but
you know these to do newsreels and you
know going to the movies was kind of
like an all-day thing it's like going to
an amusement park but since then they've
gotten less and less and they've trimmed
it down but people have really
congratulate them on bringing shorts
back at least in Disney Pixar you know
they they haven't given up on that they
still put shorts before them and you
know they can't usually get nominated
for Best Animated Short and half the
time win and they're usually very well
put together and very creative and test
new different types of animation there's
good storytelling blah blah blah this
clearly you could tell what's kind of
made just to sell dolls and toys and and
stuff like that but I will say this that
when it was done when the whole short
was done without giving anything away I
wasn't super annoyed by it I went in
ready to be annoyed by it
and by the time it was done it had very
nice scenery it had very nice songs or
acute songs it had dramatic moments they
have funny moments it was you know
visually beautiful and had a nice
message at the end so by the time I was
done I went okay we still cool froze oh
we cool but usually after a short you
know after lava and after the old guy
playing the chess game you know all
these famous shorts from Pixar after
they air or enter they're shown to the
audience there's an applause or there's
a nice lab or people yeah yeah that was
nice that was not at this short
people were just like okay like can we
start the movie now and I think a big
part of that is because it was so long
it was 21 minutes and one of the reasons
that it didn't quite annoy me as much is
because I grew up with the movie called
rescuers down under and now a lot of you
may have seen this movie most of you
didn't because the film did not do very
good the box office but if you did see
it in the theater they had a short there
with Mickey Mouse called the prince and
the pauper and this isn't like a little
5-6 minute Mickey Mouse short this was
again like half hour maybe 45 minutes I
gotta look at it again but it was a big
epic short uh and it was grand it had
like Sorcerer's Apprentice style
animation it was like cinematic
animation it was actually really good it
had like dramatic moments I have funny
moments uh you know it had all the
Disney characters and these giant
castles and just shot beautifully I mean
it was a very impressive short um and
and that came out anyway it was so long
that they put an intermission between
the short and the movie Mickey Mouse
actually comes out says oh Coke is a
popcorn and by the crack back there will
be here in five minutes and they had a
little clock ticking down for five
minutes
and I remember even as a kid I'm like we
do you know how long we just have fried
the TV I mean that this is not hard
Fritz we're gonna sit to retire the King
in you know several years here I mean we
don't need an intermission
especially kids kids can just look at a
screen forever so so I grew up with
stuff like that I also grew up in a time
where sometimes they would advertise the
short more than they would advertise the
movie you know like there's there's a
Roger Rabbit short called rollercoaster
rabbit they advertised that a lot and I
still remember that more than the movie
it played with which I think was called
far and away it was a recent way
Witherspoon the young Reese Witherspoon
movie and I don't remember a about
that but I remember roller coaster
happened because the kids they advertise
that a lot they'd ever ties the short
show all these little bits you know
playing before far in a way
see rollercoaster rabbit so the idea of
there being a lot of attention on a
short if especially from Disney is not
new but at the same time rescuers did
not do very well of far and away did not
do very well so the idea of maybe
putting longer shorts before May they
didn't do that because people do get you
know kind of upset just sitting in their
seats for so long they come there to see
a movie they already got see through
commercials before the movie starts and
previews and such you know they they
want the movie to start but my big
question is that if you saw this without
the knowledge that you're gonna watch a
movie beforehand this came on TV your
kids want to watch it or something like
that would you hate it as much my
initial thought is that if you hate the
Snowman yeah you probably would which I
get people who know who don't like Oh up
every time I see him I'm I'm ready to
hate him I'm really I'm gonna you're
gonna be charged you're gonna be charged
are but then he says funny stuff and he
says it a unique way and I'm just like
did you get lucky I'm always ready to
hate that snowman but never quite
happens but this special despite it
having some dramatic moments it's mostly
very positive it's very kid-friendly its
characters jumping up and down singing
about traditions and oh no Olaf has to
escape from some wolves and he has to go
get help and so on and so forth uh so I
can see people can't looking at that
saying there's not much substance here
but at the same time I would kind of say
you know again listen to how many songs
around there's something like five songs
and they're pretty cleverly orchestrated
the pre cleverly put together uh still
gorgeous still just beautifully animated
and photographed with the colors and the
schemes and the landscapes and so on so
forth and it still has a beginning a
middle and an end and like I said the
dramatic moments though a little out of
nowhere they
they still work and they still connect
to the characters nobody's out of
character and I'd also say that the
message at the end is kind of where I
said all right that this was okay I'm
okay with this and without giving away
too much a lot of his centers around
that you know it's about finding you
know the tradition for Elsa and Anna
because they didn't have any traditions
growing up because they were kept so
apart and the tradition they find at the
end is kind of like people at the
tradition the way that people shape them
and they shape people in some ways
literally in this case but it's one of
those things where the way we interact
with people is the tradition I know on
one hand you can be like that's a cliche
oh family that's it's always family but
I like the idea that shaping people is a
tradition is a huge part of the holiday
like that's the one thing you can always
rely on you don't hear that I think
that's a cool point of view I think
that's a cool way of talking about that
and showing that and it was a nice
little bit at the end I didn't quite
know where it was going and the way they
demonstrated and show it at the end I
thought worked I I thought was solid I
thought it was heartwarming you know
it's not it's not his heartwarming is
cocoa at the end of cocoa I think that's
the other thing to people are so
comparing the end of cocoa to the end of
this frozen short and it's like well no
yeah yeah no that was too good they had
an hour and a half to develop that to
said 20 minutes
you haven't even then 20 minutes man so
so me like a lot of people as they're
leaning over like if this was cocoa
right did we get the right movie um so
it's one of those things where I still
see a lot of positive aspects about the
short and I don't know if it's I'd say
if you don't like it you don't like it
yet you can't help that I would say if
you I would say try separating it from
the fact that this ran before not just a
movie but a really good movie and ask
yourself are there any good elements in
it that what would have you dismiss it
as much as you already do because like I
said I mean can
sitter the animation consider even
though they're bubbly you know how still
clever the songs are consider the
message and consider the fact that is
frozen it's still huge and they are
doing a sequel and they still obviously
want to keep it relevant granted you
could be sick of it you could be sick of
rows and everyone is kind of getting
sick of it and it is hard not to see the
marketing aspect in this short I
remember I leaned over and I just said
they're all gonna be a new cloth
nobody's gonna wear the same outfit even
gets a bowtie it's something different
if they have a candy cane at one point
where he puts it in and he gets a sugar
rush in his ice turned a different color
and sure enough there's that ornament to
hang up so yeah all of them are now in
different outfits to you know sell more
toys and stuff like that but I always
say it's all of it is there to kind of
sell toys does it still tell a good
story what good characters and a good
message I think it does I don't think
it's great I don't think it's phenomenal
but for a short about you know frozen
and trying to this time very directly
tie it into Christmas because sometimes
it's seen as a Christmas movie sometimes
it's not this one is straight up tying
it into Christmas now which again makes
sense and from a marketing standpoint it
makes too much sense so I think it works
okay but I can understand where people
are coming from not only with the length
not only that you're sick of frozen and
not only that seems very obvious in
terms of marketing and that it played
you know during a movie that did not
beat it like I said this should have
been shown before cars to you know our
cars three you know something where it's
like look we we don't know what people
are gonna come see this movie because
this is probably not gonna be a good
Pixar movie let's try and get you know
more people into this Coco I mean just
visually it looked amazing it was a very
cool idea
I had the emotion I I feel like even the
makers of like cars two cars three and
good dinosaur you know like they knew
this was now like okay this ain't gonna
be Toy Story this ain't you know gonna
be Lion King or frozen or anything like
that we we should put this short here
but but they put before Coco and in my
opinion I think it's still fine but I
can see where people are coming from
where they say they they don't like it
or they want it just get to the film
that's totally understandable uh again
I'm putting out there the question would
you still think that if you just saw it
on its own and it wasn't before a movie
and you might still a and I get that too
but I still think it's worth asking that
question cuz I feel like this were a lot
of hate is coming from they say like
want to see Coco I want see the damn
movie that got so much praise you know
I'm ready to cry I brought my tears
let's go
so I'd say definitely asked that
question about this short and if you
still don't like it
fair enough but I think some of you
might say maybe it wasn't that bad I
mean maybe it actually had more effort
put into it then I'm giving it credit
for
so yeah or you could hate it and you
sick of frozen either way I totally get
it I think as we're talking about cuz I
love Disney I love animation I even
still love frozen even though I'm
getting sick of it
I'm ready for Incredibles to let's bring
that bag let's start bringing those
characters back so yeah that's about it
just thought the interesting star
conversation there and let me know what
you think the comments did you love it
did you hate it or did you forget it as
soon as you saw it didn't even make an
impact that's about it I shall talk to
you later
take care
you